or uh chedrick yes where'd you grow up
where are you from originally originally
I'm from the south I'm I was born in
I was born in transporting if you want
to know Richard or you say Palm Springs
uh I spent a lot of time in Georgia in
New Orleans I was born in the house I
was in the House of the Rising Sun for
about two years
um but subsequently before then I spent
six years in a coma
uh you could say I guess it's been the
first six years of my life in a coma
when I was canistered
um basically I just grew up uh going
around the world you know on my own I
never was much of a home person I was
never much of a family person
um you're down here on skid row now all
in all I just had my apartment still
like three and a half years uh six four
nine Lofts I moved in there 321 2021
I've been in California 24 years not
seven months
and some days
but I've had my loss I waited three
years for this Loft over three years I
waited every day for this Loft
sleeping on the streets and then I moved
in there and I have been living there
since last year I was in Hollywood every
day
every night I only came to LA to do pay
my rent or see if I had to look for
somewhere otherwise I was in Hollywood
all year even though I was paying my
rent here trying to work things out with
Q my my friend
that I had asked to stay with me for a
reason told me some interesting things
outside
yes well they're true I'm not lying to
you I had three red clotias cotilliosis
reptile and me I don't know how I got
them but right here three of them I
speak eight languages I know algebra one
two and three I had never graduated
school never made it past fifth grade I
do mathematical equations and the
quadruples of algebra without even doing
it on paper
um you know you guys many mathematical
questions I bet you I can tell it to you
right off the bat uh Dynamics
Dimensions diagrams
uh uh
um other you know uh
astrology uh uh mathematical dimensions
what's 12 times 12. 12 times 12 times 12
is uh 91.
so you were telling me some other stuff
outside that uh
some people that you see that uh
that you run into here on the streets
so I'm sorry 12 times 12 909
9968 is 20 it's 21
792. it's closer
you cut yourself I don't know I haven't
been I haven't started in a few days
it's kind of been crazy for me but 12
times 12 is 24.
right okay no 12 times 12. 28. tell me
about your arms you you cut your
forearms a lot no these are from
different uh
well these are all old scars old
accidents so the stuff I send you out
there is true about uh what I was going
through like when I'm in my room why I
am in the place I'm in it's for it's for
it's secure housing it's uh
because some there's some people out
there that have needs
or they have not maybe not disabilities
but others like to try to get them tell
me outside about
um obviously
100 120 124 sorry uh
that's true I mean I I don't know if
they all right tell you that but if you
go there at night time or if you pay
attention you I mean if you were to you
would see that three people like I said
the people it's getting crazy people are
doing drugs they're overdosing uh
there's I mean everyone's acting like
not but it's not I mean look at the
population
it's getting bigger and that's not
getting smaller
you know and what were you telling me
outside though
you're telling me something
uh about my NCAA entity about my blood
being Venom it is you can take my blood
right now and test it if you want to I
give you permission I have rattlesnakes
in my room real Poison vipers I have
they're they're in my room right now my
room is a mess my room looks like a
jungle that's never clean and the swampy
marshy is the is the floor my Marsh mush
water plants seaweed all that is my
floor and trees and plants are
everywhere else that's what my room
looks like I'm probably going to get
kicked out
I mean there's I have rattlesnakes all
they come in at night in my room
sometimes they're thrown in my room when
I go recycling rattlesnakes will be put
poisonous vipers within them will be put
in in the Pursuits of the trash cans
they don't they don't bite me
pit bulls they pit bulls the most brutal
pit bulls won't attack me they try to
have them come in the room to attack me
when I'm asleep they won't attack me
until a junkyard dog pit bulls they've
never been pet or loved and they're
they're adult male or female pit bulls
they're used just to to Garden that's it
maybe not even fed properly going out
you know
um I stick with hishi the hutch stick
around
my daughter was murdered by pit bulls I
was told and my baby's mom
11 years ago I'm sorry
my only daughter
um
I'm I'm fighting I'm I hear things now
if it's not schizophrenic because they
talk to me and I talk to them and it's
not any form of psychoticness it's
called but they could say telepathy
channeling through telethonic or
paradoxical
powers or capabilities
um you know just those type of things
what I would like to do is uh
what I'll do tonight is I'll record some
things
I'll record myself in there
and my mirror in the mirror and like how
I looked in and it's not makeup I'll
have somebody I mean even security can
do it I don't care because I don't do
the makeup costume thing and not shake
like that
um the air saving air Choppers is real
that's true I did that uh from you know
I don't know how to explain it from
falling out of the sky the Earth you
know this Earth was supposed to end in
2020. there's a sports I guess fall
apart and deconsolidate in the year
2020. somebody overslept I have shot
that from happening a few times who so
you still have to you say the earth I
have yeah I've saved Earth quite a few
times
I don't know how it can be shown or it
said but it is true
that many times when air Choppers not
just airplanes but air Choppers and
helicopters are falling out of the sky
I stopped them from
continuing to fall what is your drug
oh well okay my medicine is is meth on
occasion and you know it's not like 24 7
but I do use when I have to
uh yesterday at Midnight Mission
I saved a life on Saint Julian Street on
the side of Midnight Mission
not where San Pedro is but the other
side that weird winding side street how
many lives do you think you've saved on
it
total
maybe a couple hundred I don't know
I mean I I'm told about the this money
thing that's what's pissing me off
I I just want to see
I just want to see it I want to you know
pay I don't care what I received you
know my bills are paid my rent's paid
I have food I have water soda whatever I
mean I have clothes everything you know
my phone but I want to see my bank
account you know
I want to have my ATM card
you know I want to be able to
you know what's your biggest fear in
your life my biggest fear
probably not snakes everybody
liking me and everything is going to be
okay and and it's finally like I don't
sludge down but I kind of maybe let my
my pores or something maybe get massages
a little bit you know
okay I've been living through I mean 30
over 30 years a roughneck life I mean
it's all I know that's what's comforting
me 30 years in the streets more on and
off
you know my bed was concrete and my roof
was the sky shut up
maggot
my my my bed was kept my my seat
apostrophe was the concrete ground
and my ceiling was the was the sky you
know
you've been in prison I haven't been
locked up in many years over 10 years as
far as prison tournament yes I've done a
few terms for possession of substance or
maybe I uh that's it yeah possession of
control substances you know in some
states drugs are legal others they
aren't right like there's some states
where marijuana is illegal right now you
can't smoke marijuana in like say Texas
or New Orleans or Detroit you'll go to
jail it's a felony but here we can so I
was in other states where where
marijuana was illegal and so I didn't
you know I got caught within they did me
time before
that's one reason why I moved here is
because the medicinal marijuana
well I'll take some I want to record
some things and bring it to you tomorrow
and see what happens tonight see what uh
what's the craziest thing you've seen
you want your shoes
okay craziest thing I saw okay so I'm in
a uh a loft you know I live in a lot of
Studios like type settings like this
kind of that was a wall past that that
platform here
um
so I'm in a room
no one lost I'm looking out the window I
love the view and everything but I'm
seeing like all kinds of just weird
butchering slaughtering hacking but not
human form slaughtering human forms like
demon slaughtering like vampire forms of
slaughtering demon forms things like
that the colors are really neon they're
euphoric and I love them I've seen
Michael Myers the actual Michael Edward
Myers quite a few times I mean where he
was actually
uh you know there
I know it sounds crazy but it's true and
I don't know what to say it the strength
might I mean I didn't I never used to be
able to lift 400 pounds so there's a guy
who says my building has this chrome
scooter it weighs like 400 350 to close
to 400 pounds dead solid Chrome solid
you know no Hollow bars or anything and
I lifted it up six flights of stairs
in less than two and a half minutes and
I was like what I mean just things like
that they've just been
totally insane not insane but I mean
developing in my life
you know along with a lot of other
abilities I've had how many days do you
typically stay up without sleep usually
I get sleep every night but the last
three nights I've been
um
frustrated due to lack of sex I mean you
know I don't I'm not the forceful type
or anything
all right so like I'm just I do what I
do during the day in my Lifestyles and
if I don't you know meet someone that I
don't I'm not the thrilled your
promiscuous type
um so you know it comes time you know we
have needs you know you go try to find
someone or whatever satisfied if I can't
then I'm without that night
I don't know what's going on with all
the disappearing ladies you know
um in the area uh I know some are
getting tired of it here and if they
leave and go home
you know I'm just finding out about my
baby's mom and our daughter
with the pit bull thing I can't leave
past French past Skid Row
uh due to reasons of uh security
and um
how do I see my well-being because of
financial reasons not that I own it I've
done something inadequate just maybe uh
maybe numbers more than I think I am or
I'm not worth anything at all I don't
know maybe I'm worth more than I think I
am materialistic wise and maybe I'm not
worth anything financially wise I'm not
sure have you ever been diagnosed with
any mental conditions no no
well I can't
damn I can't answer that one
so that's that's all I can think to say
is that I should record maybe some
things tonight maybe I should have done
that
does it seem like deja vu chadrick what
would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
me um
yeah you go with your guts
I was supposed to be dead listen I've
been ripped apart by pit bulls knowingly
and if anybody and if anybody disputes
this I will have no choice but to alter
a different state of emotion and stay
calm but my emotions won't be calm my
body will be calm I will stay calm but
my emotions won't be there have been
times where I wanted to just completely
just take a a baseball solid steel
baseball bat or Chrome baseball bat and
just smash as fast and as hard as I can
and but I have to stay like this
you know uh that's what it would be I've
been ripped apart knowingly by pit bulls
literally adult pit bulls
teeth things everything
I murdered I've been beat I've been
taking places where I had every bone in
my body broken I was jumped I've been
chopped up I've been put in boiler rooms
where I was in a like a furnace type
room movie murdered yeah and now these
are the people that have broken me down
to build me into a perfect machine and
now these are the ones who take care of
me if you even look at me wrong these
individuals who did this to me will
smash them on site who have you murdered
me
Lincoln Heights you can look it up I was
walking in the field and someone had
that I knew had this adult male pit bull
probably about three four feet high big
Mass Master head pit bull big teeth
ripped me apart
now
like I said the ones that put me through
my punitives and everything are now the
ones who take care of me
uh
protection wise everything if someone
were even to miss me they're not gonna
even I'm accused of horrible things they
don't even look at me now they're like
no it's not him I assuming the most
brutal you could say drill sergeants in
the world some of those brutal drill
sergeants or senses how you want to see
him
wouldn't believe it if they saw it
they'd be like no so that's that's
gracious too I'm grateful to have that
that we were able to go past all this
and now we're moving forward that right
there
you know
so all right Chadwick thank you so much
for coming in okay wish you the best of
luck out there okay thank you man